[Applaudissements]
ou d'un tatouage sur le bras
j'ai un tatoué sur le bras il ya une
phrase baisse mais a raison ça c'est
derrière moi un fait jamais je ne mange
jamais mais pour moi ok ça va céder des
femmes adorent ça mais bien qu'elle
moins de caractère homogène
je le monte jamais bon d'accord c'est
bon j'y arriverai pas assez trop sim n'a
pas y arriver je crois qu'il arrive on
arrivera c'est pas possible ça rébus à
las vegas un g10 est mais aussi un
rebelle celui-ci regardez regardez cer e
n'arrivera pas bien fait parce qu'il ya
marqué regardez ce qui s'est fait nous
lire s'est refusé de mourir ça qui l'a
marqué non pas toi je m'adresse à toi
non la traduction française d'akouda
matin
non c'est vrai bah non
s'il faut pas le dire
j'arrive pas montassier ouais c'est vrai
j'ai juste vu pedro marquer à mon avis
c'était pour son ex
bah voilà alors la [ __ ] voilà vous
avez des tatouages menu